this one is just an absolute beauty that
in a sense
doesn't surprise me but it seems like it
would be satire if you didn't know any
better
during a recent segment on fox news a
fox news anchor
asked republican senator mike braun from
indiana
whether joe biden's economy is
essentially
too good for joe biden to be doing the
things that he wants to do
this is hilarious for several reasons
which we will get to
now as many of you know the stock market
which donald trump told us would crash
if joe biden became president
has actually hit record highs new
unemployment claims
are the lowest they've been since the
start of the pandemic and they're going
lower every single week
joe biden's vaccination plan is really
popular
joe biden's coronavirus stimulus package
which passed in march
is very popular joe biden's proposed
infrastructure package is quite popular
and things are just recovering and sort
of boring and
increasingly looking good it doesn't
mean we've solved every problem or even
nearly that but
in terms of comparing to what was going
on under trump things are looking pretty
good
so here is a fox news host saying
the stock market's doing great
unemployment is down
why is joe biden doing things isn't it
dangerous to be doing things when the
economy is booming
it's almost like things are too good
take a look at this
we are seeing a booming american economy
whether it's the jobs market the the dow
as you see on your screen there
continues to hit record highs
you've got wages moving higher so why
is it that this administration wants to
spend all this money when it seems
things are getting better well that's a
good question because
the real consequences will be felt
probably post 2022
and they're calculating all this
expertly in my mind
politically isn't that just something
else
all of this time they've been denying
that things are actually going well
and now all of a sudden with concern
they say oh i don't know the economy is
booming
the stock market's booming the job
market is recovering
and yet joe biden wants to do all this
stuff i don't know that sounds like it
could be dangerous to do things when the
economy is doing so well
and mike braun of course throwing in
well you know the stuff joe biden wants
to do
won't be good in the long term it might
get them to 2022 in good shape
but it's not going to be good in the
long term which is a consideration
that they never make when they are
pulling their hair-brained economic
policy when a republican is in power
they are so desperate that it's actually
hilarious oh
no the economy is booming and yet joe
biden still is doing
things it's beyond parody they are
essentially
admitting that biden is so good at
running the country he shouldn't even
really be doing anything else
and the fact that he's trying to should
really concern all of us
the economy is doing dangerously well
under joe biden and that could be a
disaster
now there's also a serious thing here
which is of course
a lot of the jobs that are coming back
for now
are coming back part-time they were
full-time many of these jobs why well
we're in the middle of a pandemic
recovery and as as industries start to
open as different sectors start to open
some of these jobs will come back not
provisionally but on a part-time basis
many businesses operating
with reduced hours the recovery has been
disproportionately better
for the very rich than it has for
everybody else it's been real the
pandemic has been really good for the
ultra super rich and it has been that
kind of k-shaped
recovery that we've talked about before
much of the stock market performance
which has been stellar
goes to the very rich so there is a real
question
which is even though the economy is
doing quite well
for wealthy people what about everybody
else and that's exactly what joe biden's
spending programs are trying to work on
but we are at a point where even doing
well now
is considered bad if you then can
continue trying to do more things as joe
biden is trying to do
they have nothing else to whine about
we've gotten to the
is the economy too good part
of the joe biden presidency and it's
only like on month
four they were just trying to give trump
credit for the economy last week
now it's well this is biden's economy
but it's almost like it's doing
so well something must be about to go
wrong or it must be terrible for joe
biden to keep trying to do stuff
if you were to write a saturday night
live script
about how fox news would cover the
circumstances now
four months in three four months in to
joe biden's presidency
it would be indistinguishable from is
the economy doing dangerously well and
that's exactly what we're getting on fox
news
let me know what you think they will go
to next
in the manufactured crises find me on
twitter
at deepakman one of our sponsors today
is
helix sleep and it's a sponsor i'm
thrilled about because i sleep on a
helix mattress at home
and it's just the perfect mattress one
of the best things about helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do i need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type
your sleeping position your back pain
issues you might have
and they will pair you with a mattress
that will be perfect for you
i took the sleep quiz the mattress they
suggested was exactly what i needed
i often get too hot at night the
mattress keeps me cool
it's not too soft it's not too firm the
texture is right
and i've just been getting way better
sleep you only buy a mattress
every decade or so don't get stuck with
something that's not perfect for you and
all helix mattresses come with a 10-year
warranty and they'll even come to your
house and pick it up within a hundred
days
if you don't love it but i think you
will all of my viewers will get up to
200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video